when I first got married 7 years ago I
had a completely different vision of
what it meant to have a Cozy home on my
days off from work no doubt you could
likely find me at the Home Decor shops I
felt that if I could just add more throw
pillows and more candle holders and
lanterns to my already overstuffed
collection then my home would finally be
warm and inviting but it actually wasn't
until I implemented minimalism into my
life and removed all the junk that my
home finally felt cozy we've had a few
small gatherings in our home recently
and each time someone has commented that
our home feels cozy at first I figured
it's because my husband loves to be our
personal Barista and treat our guests to
lattes americanos and teas and who
doesn't love a good warm drink over
friendly chitchat but it made me stop
and reflect on what has actually made a
difference in making my home feel cozy
because ironically when I spent my days
roaming the aisles of HomeGoods my home
felt disorganized and chaotic and even
though we didn't even have kids then the
three bed two bath home that we rented
felt small probably because I stuffed
clothes in every single one of those
three closets true story we now live in
a smaller home with two kids and I've
been pleasantly surprised to find that
the things that made the biggest impact
in making our home cozy were either free
or under $50 so today I'll be sharing
with you 10 minimalist tips to make your
home cozy on a budget and I use the word
minimalist because hands down it was
minimizing and decluttering my
possessions that provided the space for
the things that I most enjoy and value
but in this video I'll mainly be sharing
with you things that you can change or
add to your space for more videos
specifically on the topic of
decluttering be sure to subscribe so you
won't miss any upcoming videos as well
as videos that I've already made on the
topic also be sure to stick to the end
from my bonus tip that changed not only
how I view my space but oddly how I view
myself as well it's good don't miss it
first step is to use warm lighting and
automatic lighting whenever possible in
a recent conversation with a friend she
mentioned that sunrise and and Sundown
are the most beautiful time of day I
wholeheartedly agreed and I think that
this is because of the warm lighting and
it's no wonder that we try to mimic this
in our own homes through things like
fires candles and warm bulbs there's
something romantic and cozy about warm
light and we can certainly tell the
difference in bright overhead office
lights as compared to a gentle flicker
of a candle if you enjoy candles the
gentle flicker can add some warmth to
the room but just swapping your lamp
bulbs to a warm color can make a big
difference we have had a set of LFX
smart bulbs for about 3 years now and I
love that I can set schedules for them
as my wakeup call they automatically
turn on in the mornings and they dim and
turn off on their own at night as a Quee
to slow down we also have some under
cabinet lighting this particular brand
is not one of my favorites but it is
rechargeable which is something that I
love it's magnetic so it basically just
has stickers on the top and I can
recharge it so it has an automatic
setting so if somebody gets up in the
middle of the night to get some water
let's say you have people over it just
automatically turns on or you can just
leave it on again this brand is not one
that I absolutely love but it is
something that I always make sure to
have charged and on when I have people
over because it just looks so much more
inviting I personally Love candles but I
like to have the non-toxic version and
they can be a little bit more pricey so
I didn't feel like constantly buying
these items so what I did is purchase
battery operated candles that have a
timer and I purchased rechargeable
batteries so basically I recharge the
batteries like twice a month and they
automatically turn on and off all on
their own in the evenings every time
we've had people over in the evenings
they make some comment about how the
home feels cozy and I hands down think
it's because of our use of warm lighting
by the way if you're curious about any
of the products that I show or mentioned
throughout this video I'll leave links
to as much as I can down in the
description box but I'm not sponsored by
any of the companies that sell these
products these are just things that I've
purchased with my own money that I've
just happened to like number two two is
to clear flat surfaces I could probably
make an entire video on this topic so
I'll try not to ramble too much here
clear Open Spaces make a room feel
larger and more like a retreat rather
than a workshop so for example the
kitchen the heart of the home consider
decluttering large unused appliances
such as that juicer you've rarely used
or that KitchenAid mixer that's become
more of a decoration you can sell or
donate your larger appliances that you
haven't used and one of the things that
I have also loved to do is to find ways
to store things inside of drawers or
within cabinets for example downsizing
your cooking spoons to your most used
will allow you to place them in a
smaller drawer you can also have an IND
drawer knife holder rather than on your
counter or eliminate your dish rack that
goes over your counter and get a small
insync one or just two like we do and
don't even have one at all you could
also declutter your spices to your
favorites and place them in a drawer or
a cabinet I've seen this done
beautifully personally I like our spice
rack candy because I use it almost daily
and I like the way it looks but look at
your counters and find what items you
never use that you can declutter and
then go from there to find in cabinet or
IND drawer solutions for the rest also
go through every single flat surface on
your home looking for knickknacks that
don't really have any sentimental value
for you sometimes the smaller items can
be a lot easier to accumulate because we
think that they don't really make much
of a difference but just for a moment
pretend that your home is a getaway
Retreat and ask yourself this question
if my home was a getaway treat what
items would it have and hopefully this
question can help you kind of figure out
what are some of those things that you
can get rid of to make more room for the
things that you do value the most
eliminating all those items that are
just adding extra clutter will make
those valued items stand out so much
more number three is to eliminate visual
clutter visual clutter is sneaky because
we don't often notice it at first glance
but it's often hiding in so many
different areas of our home I actually
have a separate video on 15 different
ways that you can eliminate visual
clutter so I'll be sure to link that
down in the description box below as
well as at the end of this video so
check that one out after this one number
four is to use natural Woods we human
beings are a part of Nature and the
beauty of nature is actually healing
I've read a study several times now but
I don't remember the source and it
basically compared ill patients in
hospitals with similar conditions and it
tracked their healing with a difference
being that one group had a window view
of Nature and the others did not the
participants with the Nature View had
improved healing times as compared to
the group that did not beauty is
inspiring and it's why people send
flowers to loved ones when they're going
through tough times or when somebody has
passed my husband loves woodworking so
we have a lot of natural Woods in the
home but because I felt that to have a
Cozy home meant that I needed to buy
more and to have more I found myself
constantly painting over them placing
knick-knacks on them oras the case of
our dinner table having all sorts of
different plac mats and table runners
and knickknacks that I call called Decor
I had this phase where I wanted to chalk
paint pretty much everything that I
could get my hands on within the house
and I had this acacia wood mail holder
that I painted blue it wasn't until
recently that I sanded it back to its
natural state and I've got to say it
feels a lot Cozier and it's a way of
bringing nature
indoors number five is to add texture
through Fabrics I am a lover of fuzzy
throw blankets so you'll always find a
blanket lying around in pretty much
every room in my house mine is the
kitchen and bathroom of course cuz that
would just be plain weird but using
natural Fabrics such as cotton linen
wool or even silk if you've got the
budget for them will give you home a
much more luxurious feel and if you
choose a neutral tone it can be the one
and only set you ever need if you use
neutrals or whites you can also play
around with the textures for example our
bed has different quilt patterns but it
still looks cohesive because of the
neutral colors this next one is
definitely dependent on personal style
so take it or leave it use warm light
colored paints for your walls and
neutral tones for your Decor such as
Woods metals and fabrics and then add
your color strategically using a color
palette my walls are actually now Ultra
Pure White from their previous blue gray
I still love blue gray walls by the way
but our home just always seemed really
dark and gloomy because the windows are
away from the sun and it just rains all
the time and painting them white made it
so much brighter I actually never
thought that I would like white walls
but I honestly don't think that I could
ever go back even though I do like
colored walls just because it reflects
so much more light but if you are a
colored lover you can keep your colored
walls but do kind of think about maybe
making your Decor have a color palette
that way it all looks cohesive so for
example I love pinks and blues but
whereas before I might have had pink
bedding and pink shower curtains now I
use these colors in just small pops
around the home number seven is to
incorporate fragrance personally I'm not
one that likes to have like the bathroom
sprays scented candles or just scented
things in general in the house because
they can be toxic and often the nontoxic
versions can be pretty pricey so what I
personally love to do is to use
essential oils in my cleaners for
example I use essential oils in my floor
cleaners and I also use them with epsom
salts to make my clothes soft and smell
delicious my favorite scent is
eucalyptus because I just find it so
relaxing and calming and that's exactly
the feeling that I want when I'm in my
home just like some people have a
signature scent as their perfume your
home can also have a signature scent or
maybe just a couple different ones that
you trade out with the seasons number
eight is to use Greenery and or add
fresh flowers plants add life to a space
and they create a feeling of nature
that's just relaxing but if you have
dark spaces or you're not ready to start
learning how to take care of plants you
can start off with a harder to kill
plants like a snake plant the pathos or
use faux plants sparingly I have these
faux plants in my office because it's a
room that does not have any Windows you
can add these sparingly to dark rooms
but make sure they're realistic looking
because otherwise it's going to give the
opposite effect of cozy and if you got a
little bit of a budget for it fresh
flowers can of course add more Beauty
and Life to a space number nine is to
add texture through rugs at the stage of
life that we're in with two small kids I
felt that it would be to my benefit to
not worry about having a rug or a nice
sofa for the moment being but I am a big
fan of rugs because they can help toine
a space and add warmth for example our
home the kitchen and living room are
open if we had a rug in the living room
it would more easily Define that space a
rug can add texture tight elements of
the room together or be a statement
piece I've definitely thought about
getting a rug like for the living room
or for our kidss room but I just don't
feel like cleaning them so realistically
it's probably not something that's going
to happen anytime soon at least not in
our near future number 10 is to
declutter and move things around if
you're on a tight budget decluttering
will not only open up your space making
it appear bigger and brighter but a huge
bonus is that it will also allow you to
clear up some space to move things
around and you also often often end up
with more bins or baskets that you can
use in different spaces to better
organize your space for example several
years ago I purchased these laundry
baskets but I do laundry pretty much
every day or every other day so I never
use them instead of decluttering them
they became storage for bedding for when
we have guests this looks much better
than having them randomly stashed in our
closet so just like I mentioned
previously when you declutter your
kitchen gadgets you're now then able to
store things within your drawers making
your space feel bigger
also decluttering large pieces of
furniture will allow you to have more
space to move things around often just
moving things around can refresh your
space and when you pair that with
decluttering it can make a big
difference my husband and I each had a
shoe rack at one point but we've now
condensed our shoes down to one instead
of getting rid of it what I did was
place it in our mud room so that we have
a nice neat area to put our shoes in and
as a bonus it also gave my kids a drop
zone for all of their paper clutter from
homeschooling some people might disagree
with me so take it or leave leave it
this is just what worked for me but when
I initially began decluttering and
decluttered more and more I initially
didn't declutter my baskets and bins and
storage stuff because as I decluttered
more I found new solutions for other
things that I could basically organize
around the home and the best part about
this is that it's totally free because
there things that are already lying in
your house that maybe just have a bunch
of clutter now that you can organize in
a different way in a different location
and as a bonus for sticking to the end H
I feel like you're not going to like me
for saying this one but it's one that I
haven't heard a lot of people talking
about and it's made a huge difference in
how I view my home especially when I
have people over and this is to
declutter hidden spaces yep I said it
that closet that you quickly stuff that
room in hoping that nothing falls out in
the process Your Clothes Closet the
drunk drawer you likely have a space
that you know you would hope nobody ever
sees if they come over but as daunting
as it might be taking an entire day or
even weeks to declutter the space can
make it a huge difference and this is
much bigger than just appearances I
can't remember why a guest followed me
to my room one day I think I was going
to give them something but my closet and
my bathroom door were both open before
that might have made me embarrassed but
now I didn't give it a second thought
I'll gladly show somebody my cboard or
my sock drawer and I'm not saying that
other people's perceptions of your space
should be what guides your decisions but
there is an effect to having that closet
that you hope nobody ever opens or
stuffing your stuff under the bed so
that it's out of sight it creates imp
imposter syndrome about your tidiness I
think that imposter syndrome is
something that we all experience when
we're trying to create change in our
lives and if you've always told yourself
the story I'm messy or I'm unorganized
you have to create a new identity for
yourself so that you begin to believe it
so when you're decluttering you're
almost symbolically speaking out
positive affirmations like I am tidy or
I value organization but because you
know that no touch closet is there you
affirm the opposite tackling hidden
clutter can be very powerful because
it's actually not about other people
it's about feeling proud of yourself for
accomplishing that daunting task it's
about your confidence in this regard I
compare it to this when I was a home
nurse I had worn out my shoes so bad
that the insides were torn up and I also
wore worn out ugly old socks that had
holes on them frankly I was just too
cheap to replace them but I didn't care
because I figured nobody's ever going to
know until when day I went to visit a
patient on a rainy muddy day and I took
off my shoes before entering their house
but the entire time that I was there I
hoped that nobody would look down at my
feet or notice my shoes needless to say
even though I'm not a home nurse anymore
I always wear nice socks and I make sure
that my shoes are clean and not tearing
apart and even if I never have another
unexpected takeoff your shoes moment
it's now not going to be something that
robs me of my energy that I could use
towards positive constructive thoughts
decluttering a hidden space will give
you that same I have clean socks feeling
that I gained like a secret only you
know about some people also like to have
an empty shelf or a drawer in their home
just for the sake of knowing that it's
there it's like a subliminal reminder of
the change that you're making your own
secret confidence booster so if you're
up for the challenge let me know down in
the comments below what is that hidden
space that you will be challenging
yourself to declutter you got this also
be sure to share what are some of your
favorite ways to make your home cozy I'd
love to learn from you and if you like
this video don't forget to give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so you won't
miss when I post a new video I thank you
so much for watching and I'll see see
you in the next one bye for now